e g is one of the technique to record
macroscopic electrical activity by
placing electrodes in the scalp
the EEG recording represent the
population level activity at the surface
level of the brain
so here is how the electrodes are placed
on the scalp and the macroscopic
population level activity of the neurons
are recorded via this kind of method
so all these recordings are
corresponding to a micro volt level
fluctuation in the signal and these
signals correspond to teeny tiny changes
in the potential
in the neurons at the surface level of
the brain and that correspond to the
voltage oscillations
EEG signatures can be understood or
interpreted by a neuropsychiatis
to understand the brain activity it's a
good diagnostic tool for epilepsy
patients also it can help to monitor
Sleep Quality